new details in an officer-involved  shooting that left one man wounded it  happened tuesday night at a mobile home  park near pecos and lake mead when metro  officers responded to reports of a man  apparently just walking around with a  gun  face the car  let me make sure you don't have any  weapons on you  so that is 25 year old tavion davidson a  body worn camera here showing him  running away before pointing and then  firing one shot at the officers that's  when two officers fired a total of 19  times  davidson was still able to get over a  fence where he eventually gave himself  up metro says officers acted bravely in  this situation  unfortunately we continue to deal with  this sort of violence against police  officers  across the country and certainly here in  las vegas  and we were able to apprehend the  suspect safely  before he was able to hurt anybody in  the complex  davidson is still in the hospital but is  expected to survive